richard branson the man with the golden
touch
and the billionaire smile he's
fabulously rich
famous as a rock star and he always
seems to be having a really good time
i've been extraordinary fortunate i've
enjoyed every minute of my life
i wouldn't swap my life with anybody
he's not
impressed by wealth he's more bored
about do i have fun
and don't have excitement you gotta have
the balance branson parlayed a sexy name
virgin into branding gold and astounding
300 plus goods and services
from rock to air travel to cell phones
to trains we have taken on the big fat
bloated companies that have
not really thought too much about the
consumer and we've gone in and shaken
them up
if you'd analyze the risks that richard
was taking wouldn't take him
because no risk analysis would say go
ahead with this to keep it all afloat
branson became his own best pitch man
living out the virgin values of
adventure and fun
even if it meant putting his own life on
the line
i do seem to have conceived almost every
way known to man
to try to kill myself and i've been very
fortunate to be here today to talk about
some of these stories
[Music]
if such a title actually existed richard
branson might really be
the most interesting man in the world he
owns his own island
balloons around the globe works with
world leaders
and he plans to take a virgin submarine
to the uncharted bottom of the ocean
floor
his riskiest adventure yet you only live
once and
we accept that there are risks attached
to doing something that mankind hasn't
done before but
we go we go there with our eyes open
branson has spent much of his life
on the high wire of entrepreneurial risk
he has amassed a personal fortune of
more than four billion dollars
don't be bad i've never been interested
in
uh making money i mean it um easy to say
i suppose people might say when you have
made money but
i i've just been interested in creating
things and creating things that i could
be proud of
and um and you know having a lot of fun
creating things
richard charles nicholas branson was
born on july 18
1950 to middle class parents on the
outskirts of london
his father was a barrister his mother
was a former flight attendant
severely dyslexic he could barely read
by the age of eight
and was hopelessly lost with numbers
school was
painful you know i'd look at look at a
blackboard and wouldn't be able to
understand anything that was
going on interestingly if you look at
the
history of dyslexics they often
exceed quite exceptionally because they
concentrate on the areas that they
that they're good at it's certainly
taught the art of delegation from
quite a young age nick powell was
branson's closest
friend and future business partner i
always thought with richard
that he was going to make an impact on
the world
you could tell from a relatively early
age that he had
qualities that were not common amongst
all the other friends that that we had
we used to play dare sitting on either
side of the white line
and it was the last one a move when the
car came down the road richard always
won the games of there
but branson had a strong entrepreneurial
streak
when he was 13 he tried growing
christmas trees for sale
he tried breeding parakeets at 15
he decided to launch a national student
newspaper
i worked out of a phone box at my school
ringing up coca-cola ringing up
you know people to try to write for the
magazine ringing up
barclays bank to try to get them to
advertise you know the queues of people
outside the phone box as i was shoving
more money into the into the phone
the magazine student was an instant hit
with a circulation of 50 000.
graham boyton is a former travel
reporter for the london telegraph
and covered branson for over 20 years
although he was a child of the sixties
he was always slightly awkward
so i think what happened was the
business gave a vocabulary a raise on
debt and and that's
and he and he went from there in 1970
branson started a mail order discount
record company
that he hoped would raise money for the
magazine the first order of business
was coming up with a name somebody
suggested slip disk records
we had the you know the old vinyl disc
which kept on slipping
and somebody else laughed you know why
not virgin
we're all virgins and hysterical after
all all around
um and and i suddenly thought i am
virgin at business
um you know i might be a virgin at other
things as well and you know why not
a postal strike in 1971 nearly
deflowered the mail order record
business
so branson decided to open a record
store one with headphones and water
pillows that catered to a younger
generation
simon draper branson's cousin was his
first record buyer
and the future head of virgin records
everyone was paid the same
so this there was just a kind of a
feeling that no one should be earning
any more money than anyone else but if
you stop to think about it it was
actually convenient
to have everyone paid the same because
it could pay everyone less some of the
people who worked for richard in the
record shops
in in notting hill they used to steal
the records out of the shops
and they were absolutely amazed when
richard fired them
for stealing he was wired to be a
businessman
from from day one five months after
opening the virgin store
branson was suddenly arrested for tax
evasion
he was discounting his records in part
because he had figured out a way to get
around
a 33 percent record tax he spent a night
in jail
and his parents had to put up their home
to get him out
he thought that the part of getting in
last game was to avoid
paying tax and i think that must have
come as a huge shock to richard he was
extremely upset
but he behaved impeccably he carried the
can so no one else
had any penalties i had managed to
avoid a criminal offense by paying what
the customs and exercise needed
and we expanded our record shops very
quickly so we could get the turnover in
order to pay
you know pay off the debt since then
i've made sure that we've done
everything
ethically and you know without without
worry that someone's going to come
knocking on our door
to pay off a 150 000 fine
and avoid going to court and possibly
prison branson rolled the dice on some
new ventures
including a recording studio and a new
record label
which he launched with his cousin simon
draper
their first signing was an unknown folky
named
mike oldfield with an odd instrumental
album called
tubular bells
[Music]
well we're asking each other to take a
punt at what we thought it was going to
sell
and i seem to think that i thought it
would sell 20 000 copies
which seemed a lot to me at the time
but millions later you know very
different story
16 million to be precise overnight
the record put virgin on the map
and made richard branson not yet 23 a
millionaire
branson poured his profits into new
artists and ventures
but his willingness to reinvest all his
winnings unnerved his partners
nick powell put up so much resistance
that branson
bought him out i didn't believe we had
enough cash flow to sustain
the expansion of the company and i was
wrong
i'm willing to double down maybe more
than i
recommend to other people there have
been occasions where i've got my wife to
sign this bit of paper and she hasn't
realized that the house has been put on
on the line for the next business
venture
by 1984 richard branson was living the
life of a rock and roll
kingpin he owned this island in what
else
the british virgin islands and virgin
records was one of the most successful
independent labels in the world
the sex pistols simple minds
human league culture club were all
million selling acts branson was flush
with cash
and looking for ways to spend it out of
the blue
an insurance lawyer named randolph
fields called
and asked branson to back him on a
transatlantic airline
simon draper you know and my other poor
partners would be
tearing their hair out because uh you
know suddenly
you know i was saying you know i hate
traveling on other people's airlines and
we can do it better my shares um
which i owned at that time 15 of the
whole virgin group
um were becoming pretty valuable so i
was appalled
and i said this is the beginning of the
end of our relationship
[Music]
branson launched his airline with a
single used 747 that he leased from
boeing
the guy from boeing said um you know
what did you say the name of your
company was i said well
virgin um you know we're the people that
brought you the sex whistles the rolling
stones
he just slightly jokingly said well you
know with a name like that
you know we hope your airline will go
the whole way um and
um you know we'll we'll give it a go
after buying fields out of the
partnership branson decided to offer an
upgraded mix of economy
and business class fares with a big
emphasis
on non-stop fun
[Music]
virgin's inaugural flight from london to
new york
set the tone
let me tell you it was a back an alien
orgy i mean it was
wild there was drinking there were
topless models on the plane
it was eleven party and richard led from
the front
david tate the first person branson
hired was an executive
with virgin atlantic when the daughter
of the airplane opened at newark
it was kind of like a champagne cork
coming out of a bottle because to this
day i think there was still a
record number of champagne bottles drunk
on that flight over
with just one plane and one route
branson's first
problem was promotion he didn't have the
advertising budget to compete with
british airways and the other giant
carriers
so he took matters into his own hands
embarking on a series of breathless
ballooning and boating adventures
that would quickly turn virgin airlines
into a household
name beginning of a great adventure
his 1987 flight across the atlantic
fascinated world media for weeks
five people had died in earlier attempts
per linstrand was branson's co-pilot
he would entirely put his life in my
hands and
i must see his houseguards
[Music]
as they eased the balloon into the irish
sea fierce winds tossed them against the
waves
my fellow blueness and the more
experienced blueness jumped jumped out
of the balloon
i was left in this balloon on my own
and the balloon spiraled up to you know
ten fifteen thousand feet
if i'm in the water rich is in the
balloon he doesn't really know how it
works
that was scariest moment in my life
branson managed to lower the balloon and
jumped into the freezing water
a royal air force helicopter fished him
out along with pair
who nearly died after swimming in place
for two hours
i used to like to describe richard as a
cross between evel knievel
and ted turner he'll always tell you
that i'm ballooning because it's great
publicity for the company
baloney he's doing it because he enjoys
it if he were a cat he'd be on his third
set of nine lives
by the end of 1989 richard branson's
world was expanding on all fronts
he married his longtime partner joan
templeman in a ceremony on necker island
the couple already had two kids
four-year-old sam
and eight-year-old holly the company was
also branching out
branson had taken the virgin group
public in 1986
with an ipo that generated more than 56
million dollars
i don't think going public will make
that bigger difference
um to the way we conduct our business
that turned out to be wrong
it did make a difference branson chafed
had been accountable to an outside board
and bought back virgin after two years
he now presided over a small but
precarious empire
with a growing airline that was in
constant danger of going under
and worse british airways was determined
to crush its upstart rival
the rivalry between british airways and
virgin atlantic
has always puzzled me i think it was
down to
british establishment seeing this young
upstart with long hair
sort of reckless motor mouse airline
entrepreneur and it really cheesed them
off
so much so that in 1991 british airways
launched what the press called
the dirty tricks campaign they had teams
of people
you know behind closed doors illegally
accessing our computer information
ringing our passengers pretending to be
from virgin atlantic saying we had
you know flights that were cancelled and
switching them on to british airways
they had people going through my rubbish
bins
going through the rubbish bins of our
clubs um you know trying to
uh you know pick up any any kind of dirt
on us
you know they were placing stories in
the press and so on and so on most
damagingly
branson was convinced that british
airways was stoking rumors that virgin
was insolvent
and about to go under will whitehorn is
the former head of virgin galactic
and has worked closely with branson
since 1987.
every day you take off if you've got
empty seats you've lost money
so if somebody can persuade passengers
not to book with a certain airline
because they think it's going to go bust
it will go bust branson was fighting to
keep virgin atlantic alive
and once again he put his life on the
line to do it
he took off on another dangerous
promotional balloon trip
this one over the pacific
[Music]
pressurizing all right
in the middle of the pacific we lost two
full fuel tanks
and we didn't know we had enough fuel to
make it do we have any chance
we knew that we had to fly this balloon
at an average speed of over 180 miles an
hour
and that was just blown by the wind and
so the the chances of that happening
were extraordinarily unlikely
but we got right into the core of the
jet stream and suddenly
saw the speedometer going 150 160 170
180 190 200 210 220
i'm not a religious person but it was as
if somebody up there had just taken that
balloon and was just
pushing it pushing it through the jet
stream
branson and lindstrand crash landed on a
frozen lake
300 miles from the nearest habitation we
missed what we're aiming for by
um three and a half thousand miles and
landed in the arctic in a snowstorm
at minus 60 degrees but we couldn't have
been happier in fact
by the time branson thought out he was a
superstar
his record label was heating up too
virgin records
signed janet jackson and the rolling
stones to multi-year deals
but in the short term it was irrelevant
british airways dirty tricks campaign
against virgin atlantic
was making it impossible to get credit
to save the airline
branson had to make the toughest call of
his life
he decided to sell his beloved record
company
penny pike served as his personal
assistant for 31 years
everyone was terribly shocked i mean
richard was
more shocked than most people but he
cried and cried and cried
it was a bit like selling a child i told
the staff
burst into tears ran you know ran down
back towards my house with tears
streaming down my face
he passed this sign that said branson
sells for a billion dollars
and i realized life wasn't wasn't that
bad he secured the future of virgin
atlantic
because he had enough capital behind him
after that to be able to
look any competitor in the face and say
well you know i can you know i can sit
this out as long as you can people said
at the time
we were mad to you know sell the record
company to put the money into an airline
as it turns out of course the record
industry's collapsed and
the airline industry hasn't done too
badly for us one month
after the billion dollar label deal
branson sued british airways for libel
the airline settled out of court and
paid branson a record
1.1 million dollars
we won the biggest libel damages of any
libel case
um and you know they had to make a
public apology
[Music]
oh richard branson was elated that day
was probably one of the great days of
his business career
he'd done it he stomped on the mighty
british airways
that night he was on the phone to
various people
and he had this real determination his
voice
that this was the moment you know that
he was going to make virgin atlantic a
global success
and he was going to take this company
and grow it around the world
after selling virgin records for a
billion dollars in 1992
richard branson was ready to exploit his
most valuable asset
the virgin brand we suddenly realized
you know we actually have
you know something which is something
we've got to protect and we've got to
nurture the brand is ultimately is what
what virgin's all about
branson was the brand and he tirelessly
promoted it
to date he has virginized over 300
products and services
i think generally if you can create
something you can be proud of
it's likely to be successful i wasn't
thinking
right let's just take this brand into
lots of different areas i just
felt you know we can we can we can do
better in health clubs we can do better
in mobile phone business some ventures
like virgin brides and virgin cola
fizzled quickly then the brand stumbled
with
virgin trains the acquisition came with
a dilapidated infrastructure
and it took years to get the trains to
run on time
but some endeavors have been
breathtaking in their success
in 1999 branson struck paydirt
he partnered with service providers to
launch virgin mobile
they supplied the network he supplied
the marketing and name
and the innovative idea of letting
customers pay as they go
bert schmidt a professor at columbia
university's school of business
is an expert in branding the value of a
brand is really in the intangibles
because customers
are not just buying products they're not
just buying functionality they're also
buying an image they're buying a
lifestyle
they're buying an experience he stands
for certain things he stands for service
for customer experience for innovation
for fun
branson was now business royalty and was
honored in 1999
by his country's royalty he was knighted
by the queen
as a millennium icon for his
contribution to commerce
[Music]
becoming sir richard did nothing to slow
him down
five years later he took virgin mobile
public
with an ipo that he said valued the
company at 1.5 billion dollars
[Music]
branson made each of his new ventures an
independent company
so that no single failure could bring
the empire down
nevertheless analysts have regularly
questioned the value of the virgin group
which is still privately held the
headlines would be you know when's
branson's balloon going to burst
and every time we started something new
you know stretching the brand too thin
and and sometimes they went far off the
truth
the virgin group continued to spin off
new ventures
and in 2004 branson announced one of his
most imaginative
he was going to take people into outer
space beginning
with his own mother i think we're within
about 18 months
of going up into space and then starting
a whole new area of commercial spaceship
travel
hopefully hundreds if not thousands of
people will be able to have
the chance to become astronauts and go
into space
it's a huge risk it's rather like
putting your name
your brand on a formula one race car
it's great when it's winning but if it
ends up wrapped around a concrete pole
somewhere then
then it has a lot of downside branson
stretched the virgin brand even farther
in 2006
with his own airline spewing tons of co2
into the atmosphere
he pledged to spend all profits from his
transportation companies over the next
ten years
an estimated three billion dollars to
fund research for an eco-friendly
biofuel
he also launched the council of elders a
crisis intervention dream team
led by nelson mandela i'd reached the
age of 55
i'd made um good money
so i could pick up the phone pretty well
anybody and cut through and get things
done
suddenly i was in a position where i
could maybe make a difference in the
world
critics have scoffed at the new socially
minded branson
and point to the offshore tax shelters
he has used for decades to protect his
wealth
i don't think which is any different to
the other very very wealthy
businessmen who've got armies of
accountants and lawyers
telling them we know where to put their
money where to hide their money
is he the people's entrepreneur
only up to a point branson hasn't been
able to safeguard all of his assets
virgin america had a rough time getting
off the ground
and lost nearly 400 million dollars
before beginning to turn a profit in the
third quarter of 2010
[Music]
as he heads into his 60s it's been a
long and thrilling journey for the
virgin king
branson has made his own luck i think
he's been very very
good at it so it's not just a golden
touch i think he's worked for it
of course he's driven by money but he's
not impressed by wealth
he's more bothered but do i have fun and
don't have excitement
you've got to have the balance i've been
extraordinarily fortunate
i've enjoyed every minute of my life
going forward
most of my time will be spent on setting
up not-for-profit enterprises
and seeing them in attacking some of the
big problems in the world
um but at the same time you know we will
still have wonderful adventures go go to
space
go to the bottom of the oceans and still
push ourselves and challenge my children
and challenge the people around me and
have a blast